fallout tonight following the pentagon's  admission that a recent drone strike in  afghanistan was quote a tragic mistake  the government revealed friday that 10  civilians seven of them children were  killed that day instead of terrorists  they believe were responsible for the  kabul airport bombing tonight government  officials say the families of those  killed in the drone strike want justice  responsible for this strike and this  tragic outcome we felt reasonably  certain that this was a legitimate  strike on an imminent isis k threat the  pentagon press secretary said the  secretary of defense has now called for  an immediate review of this  investigation